our theme in this lecture is November
the 22nd 1963 the assassination of
President John Kennedy now someone asked
me how can you say that the
assassination of John Kennedy changed
history why is it worthy to rank
alongside the will say law Code of
Hammurabi well in the first place anyone
who was of reasoning years so let's say
10 or above right in 1963 knows forever
that the assassination of this president
changed his or her life and will believe
to the end of their days that it changed
the history of our country you have to
remember that I am an unabashed patriot
I believe that America is the greatest
greatest force for good that the world
has ever known and the assassination of
President Kennedy changed America and
it's reverberations are with us still
today it was and this is a very
meaningful expression in these terms it
was a loss of innocence for our country
and it was a loss of a sense that the
whole of our future would be ever upward
Kennedy was a flash of brilliance amidst
the rather dreary America of not the
1950s that was the age when the Cold War
seemed at its height though I must also
tell you I don't think the Cold War has
ever ended but the Cold War seemed at a
height in the 1950s we had a very
well-meaning President Eisenhower he was
very popular he was deeply patriotic he
believed in his duty to uphold the law
he believed in his duty to contain
communism but he
wasn't very striking or inspiring and
our foreign policy seemed to be one
group of setbacks after another China
lost in 1949 reports coming out of China
of famines in which millions died the
Soviet Union boasting that it would bury
America and bury capitalism and then
even sending a satellite into space
faster than we did our whole educational
system began to question itself because
communist communism seemed to be working
better in education even so it was a
gloomy time for Americans and suddenly
there was John Kennedy and the world
became brighter for us he was born like
Roosevelt whom he admired enormous li2
wealth and privilege in fact his father
Joseph had been ambassador to Great
Britain in the very time that Britain
seem most likely to collapse before the
Germans in fact in the spring of 1940
Joseph Kennedy had sent telegram after
telegram to President Roosevelt saying
the British won't fight they're going to
collapse and don't send them any aid and
of course Roosevelt listened to the
speech of Churchill we shall never
surrender and gave the British all the
aid he possibly could but Joseph Kennedy
was a very astute businessman serious
diplomat connected as high as possible
throughout America and widely connected
in Europe and in fact while he was an
ambassador there in London his son John
was there studying a bit at the London
School of Economics finishing up his
Harvard honours thesis which was on why
England slept Winston Churchill had
written a very powerful treatise called
while England slept which described
I why the Nazis were able to build such
a war machine but Kennedy went into the
politics of why the English had it first
followed a policy of appeasement and
negotiation gaining time for themselves
to become a match for the military power
of Germany one of his professors at
Harvard gave it a Magna cume Lauda the
other just gave it a comb Lauda but it
is a very fine book and of all our
presidents Theodore Roosevelt and I
believe John Kennedy are the best
authors Thomas Jefferson was a genius
but he didn't write all that much it
would call a book but Kennedy wrote this
book on England in the interwar years I
came back to this country and was a war
hero his older brother was killed in
action and Kennedy was almost killed in
action pt-109 the name will live forever
for Americans of the 1950s and 60s
pt-109
sunk Kennedy exhibiting great valor and
winning medals saving his crew and as
always had a little witty thing to say
about it how did you win those medals
huh I got my boat sunk so a war hero and
he now became his father's objective for
political power and he ran for this
Congress as soon as he got back and then
was elected to the Senate he was a
dutiful senator married very well I took
a moderate approach the things like
civil rights but was very strong on
national defense and when he ran in 1960
it looked as always going to be a very
close election
Eisenhower of course could not run hits
and it was going to be his vice
president Richard Nixon a very capable
and experienced man but it would be his
opponent well there was Lyndon Johnson
absolute master of the Senate capable
shrewd crafty politician and it looked
as though he would sweep to an easy
victory but Americans didn't want a
politician of that old stripe and
Kennedy grabbed their attention and in
hard-fought campaigns spending a great
deal of money Kennedy won the nomination
and then he took Lyndon Johnson on as
his vice president balancing his
Massachusetts geography with Lyndon
Johnson's Texas balancing his
aristocratic background with Johnson's
homespun humor and they won but like
everything that John Kennedy did it
didn't come easily there were enormous
discussions over vote fraud but he was
inaugurated as president and there on
that brilliant cold January day snow
lying all around John Kennedy was
inaugurated giving the most inspiring
speech since Franklin Roosevelt had
given his first inaugural address and a
speech that would highlight the values
of America at mid-century the highlight
of the American century as it would
already be called his beautiful wife
their charming speaking perfect French
another breath of fresh air sweeping
across the country mrs. Eisenhower had
been such a nice lady but she was your
grandmother Oh Jackie Kennedy dressed
beautifully and an elegant air about
everything that she did and so he spoke
and he told the world that a new
generation was in America now it was a
generation that had fought the war and
been hardened by a cold war
it was a generation that was taking up
the torch of freedom and throughout that
inaugural address he calls Americans to
their role in bearing freedom to the
world just as certainly as President
Bush would in his second inaugural
Kennedy insisted that freedom is a
universal value that all people and in
all places and at all times want freedom
and it is our duty to bring it to them
he demands that we dedicate ourselves to
our country and to our country's great
mission he wants us to ask not what our
country can do for us but what we can do
for our country he demands that we reach
out to the world let us never negotiate
he says out of fear but never let us
never fear to negotiate those words
still when you read them inscribe there
at Arlington Cemetery move you to tears
and it was a call to young Americans and
he immediately gave them a task as
important as Roosevelt had with his
Civilian Conservation Corps this was the
Peace Corps and thousands of young
people would feel a new sense of doing
something for their country learning a
foreign language going off to help bring
hygiene to places in Africa and Asia
going to Persia going to teach English
in schools caught up in this fervor that
now America was once again on the move
and things could change and he took a
bold stand on civil rights when the
University of Mississippi students
rioted because an African American
student had enrolled he sent the troops
in he wasn't afraid of controversy
people said you can't make your
other attorney-general why said Kennedy
he needs the experience needs experience
of being a lawyer he had this
magnificent way of dealing with the
press
no president except Franklin Roosevelt
has been anywhere near his equal as a
speaker to a large crowd as a holder of
press conferences and as a debater on
television and again see the old footage
there is Vice President Nixon looking
much more experienced knowing a great
deal more than Kennedy but looking
shifty eyed and nervous under the
cameras and even little sweat coming out
on his lips Kennedy never showed he was
worried at all and from that first
debate on TV he was going to win and he
carried that Majesty all through his
term as president so a strong stand on
civil rights calling the youth of
America to a new task and then a firm
foreign policy because Kennedy was the
product of the cold war cold war that we
saw led to the communist takeover of
China the cold war that led to the
Soviet atomic bomb the cold war that all
through the 1950s had everybody in
America terrified that one day might be
their last Dave because of atomic
explosion kids were taught to dive under
their desk in case there was an atomic
explosion that was never explained to me
in those days how that would help me
kids were even issued dog tags so that
they could be identified once this
nuclear holocaust had come but from the
beginning
Kennedy was determined to negotiate
negotiate not out of fear but not
fearing to negotiate and so he met with
the then Soviet leader Nikita Khrushchev
could not imagine two more different
people meeting there in Vienna their
handsome debonair well
dressed Kennedy born and out in wealth
and privilege and Khrushchev would grown
up a peasant Khrushchev a great fat man
bald-headed snaggletooth and a brute a
hooligan he had been in charge in the
1930s of Stalin's systematic starvation
of millions of Ukrainians he had risen
to power after Stalin's death by
treachery and brutality and so he met
with the young president and the first
test of Kennedy didn't go so very well
Khrushchev decided he was weak he was
young and inexperienced and he decided
Khrushchev did and the Soviet Politburo
went along with him that America itself
was weak and would not stand up after
all it's been only seven years since the
Korean War had come to an end and there
from Khrushchev's point of view in that
war the Americans had not been willing
to fight to the end they weren't willing
to use the atomic bomb they wouldn't
take that final step and perhaps the
greatest sign of weakness of all was
Cuba going all the way back to President
James Monroe we had said European powers
have no business in America all through
the 1920s we had patrolled places like
Haiti clear sign of our ability to
enforce our will in the Western
Hemisphere and no one else dare
interfere but Fidel Castro had
overthrown the corrupt dictator Batista
and once again the American State
Department the late 50s looked totally
uninformed just the way it had been in
China they looked upon or proclaim
Castro to be sort of a an agrarian
reform well he was a communist and he
said in place one the most ruthless
communist dictatorships in the world
every bit as ruthless as Mao Zedong's
China and suddenly there was a communist
foothold in the Western Hemisphere now
again and
lest you live during the 50s and 60s the
word communist doesn't just doesn't
invoke the kind of fear it did to people
then but communism was synonymous with
evil children grew up believing that
once the Communists took over America
they would confiscate your Bible and
there were wonderful movies made like
the invasion of the body snatchers
the original version in which these pods
come to earth but every one of us
immediately in watching the movie said
aha
that's how the Communists are going to
come they're going to take over our
bodies and we'll look just the same but
you will be doing evil communist things
so here was a communist foothold in the
Western Hemisphere and President
Eisenhower had done nothing about it
and Kennedy at the very start tried to
do something about it and failed there
was a plot already underfoot when he
became president to land Cuban exiles at
a place called the Bay of Pigs there in
Cuba and overthrow Fidel Castro and the
Communists rather like when we went into
Iraq some years ago everybody was
convinced at the high government levels
that these Cuban exiles would be
recognized as liberators well they
weren't the Cuban army was extremely
well-trained armed with Chinese and
Soviet guns and it was a fiasco and
Kennedy early on in his administration
looked totally incompetent in foreign
affairs you could literally one of his
friends say see him begin to sink into
his chair and once said to another Jack
Kennedy's never lost anything
so the Bay of Pigs was a fiasco and
Khrushchev picked up on it and that was
another sign that America would not go
the whole length and America was
possessed of nuclear missile sites that
surrounded Russia for example there in
Turkey
so Khrushchev decided that missiles
bearing nuclear warheads could be put
into Cuba and the Americans would do
nothing about it
Fidel Castro wanted their weapons there
they would be his security
and so came about the Cuban Missile
Crisis of 1962 almost the way they had
done at Roosevelt's first inaugural
Americans crowded around their
televisions of radios that evening as
Kennedy lay out exactly what was going
to happen that these missiles were there
in Cuba they were in violation of our
Monroe policy that if we allow them to
stay there no friend or foe would ever
take our word seriously and of course he
had many in the government who wanted
him to drop the big ones start it let's
get this nuclear war over but no he was
a pragmatic politician John Kennedy was
a patriot he was an idealist at and he
was pragmatic and he and his advisors
his brother playing a key role Robert
Kennedy they found the way out that
allowed the Soviets to save some face we
took away obsolete missiles from Turkey
Russians took out their missiles no
armed engagement took place and the
world breathed easier he had not
negotiated out of fear but he had not
fear to negotiate
and so that dreaded nuclear holocaust
was postponed and he went to Europe he
didn't Globetrotter great deal but he
went to Europe taking his beautiful wife
with him speaking her French and
introducing himself as I'm a Jacqueline
Kennedy's husband in the crowds in his
hand but going to Berlin to make a
statement see in those years Berlin was
divided by a Great Wall one side was
East Germany a constant statement of the
failure of communism to work down at the
heels gray
drab many of the destructions from the
war many buildings that were ruined
never even repaired and on the other
side the Wild West Berlin a little
island of freedom amidst a communist
world bustling well fed well clad people
saying what they wanted writing what
they wanted and Kennedy went there and
proclaimed our utter devotion to the
freedom of Germany and Berlin once again
Khrushchev Russians believe that America
would back down and they might be able
to take over all of Berlin well it
didn't happen if been ein bier Lena he
said and the translator said ich bin IE
bailina and Kennedy stoppin said I want
to thank the translator for translating
my German again the crowd was his and no
nation mourned more deeply when Kennedy
was killed than did the Germans so a
strong and vigorous foreign policy but
he was not loved by every American even
news media like Time magazine were
frequently critical of him there were
elements in the african-american
community who weren't sure how deep his
commitment to civil rights actually was
and he was hated as weak on communism by
very influential well-funded groups
throughout America who looked upon him
as a communist of course some of these
were the same people who had called
Dwight Eisenhower a conscious tool of
the International communist conspiracy
but nonetheless Kennedy was hated by
them and then in the South he was looked
upon as far too strong on his civil
rights policy and there were many in the
Democratic policy in the Democratic
Party who hated him so
the question of whether he would
actually win re-election became a real
one already in the fall of 1963 would he
win re-election he was confident he
would because on the one hand was John
Kennedy and really most Americans who
believed in a moderate approach to
containing communism in other words not
blowing ourselves up who believed in a
moderate approach to civil rights who
believed that African Americans had the
right to vote to go to a school they
wanted to have all the freedoms of every
American and there were also believed
that an educated public devoted to its
country was willing to consider many
different forms of ideas that even
fundamental tenets of Marxism were worth
debating openly and on the other hand
was a minority that found its embodiment
in Barry Goldwater now Goldwater was a
very patriotic man he was an intelligent
man but he became the embodiment of
these ideas that communism must be
absolutely resisted that it was better
to be dead than red and that America
must pursue a return to a social and
economic system back into the time of
Herbert Hoover Kennedy accepted the New
Deal he wanted to make it work ever
better he wanted to expand health care
we were past Herbert Hoover's days he
believed in a liberal approach to the
economy
he believed that Kennedy did that
government had an important role in the
economy one of his most trusted advisors
and one of his speech writers was John
Kenneth John Kenneth Galbraith ah who
was responsible for some of the very
witty phrases that Kennedy used so he
believed in a liberal view of the
economy with govern
and having a role in it and barry
goldwater said government has no role
whatsoever and Kennedy was quite
convinced that the Republican Party was
so delft self-destructive that they
would nominate Barry Goldwater which is
what they'd actually did in 1964 so he
thought he would win but the question as
far as he was concerned pragmatically
was who would going to be his vice
presidential candidate and Lyndon
Johnson just had not worked out Lyndon
Johnson was very loyal to Kennedy uh
Kennedy was very good with Johnson
keeping him informed as much as possible
about everything that was developing
including Johnson and every important
meeting but Johnson just had not proven
to be what Kennedy thought he would be
that is to say John Kennedy believed
that Johnson having been the master of
the Senate when he was a senator could
continue to be sick and could continue
successfully to twist arms in the Senate
and get senators to vote the way he
wanted them to and Johnson just was a
man now without a power base in the
Senate senators just didn't listen to
him he was vice president and as more
than one president well more than one
vice president has said it's a job being
vice president that's not worth a
pitcher of warm spit so Johnson just
wasn't able to have the political clout
Kennedy Don had hoped for and moreover
cod's Johnson didn't seem to be able
even to control the Democratic Party in
Texas it was badly split between a
liberal side that admired Kennedy and a
very conservative Democratic faction
that was opposed to civil rights wanted
a doctrinaire approach to communism
wanted government totally out of
business and they had fallen out senator
Yarborough and the governor of Texas
John Connally we're not even speaking so
if Johnson couldn't even control the
Democratic Party in Texas how much help
would he would be would he be but
Kennedy decided to give Johnson another
chance and agreed to go on a
good will trip to Texas try to get the
feuding parts of the Democratic Party
together again and give some exposure to
his ideas well he was warned against it
addley stevenson one of the real pet
hatreds of this conservative wing of
america had been to Dallas and he had
been beaten on the head with posters
held up by protesters he begged Kennedy
not to go to Dallas it's dangerous and
there were even some in Texas who said
you know you were really hated here
don't come but Kennedy was never a man
to be afraid he and mrs. Kennedy flew
into Fort Worth going to speak to the
Chamber of Commerce that morning of the
22nd she was late and he said mrs.
Kennedy is late but when she gets here
she looks a whole lot better than the
rest of us then they flew on from Fort
Worth to Dallas it wasn't necessary but
the press Secretary's believed
presidential landings getting off of a
plane that always looked good so they
landed and they began that drive that
procession coming before the Texas Book
Depository and there as we are told was
this lone assassin Lee Harvey Oswald a
failure and everything he had done who
it's been a good deal of time in Russia
whose background was never fully
understood his reasons for what he did
never clear but if what we are told is
true he fired that rifle with
extraordinary marksmanship and he had
been a marksman in the Marines and John
Kennedy was dead 12:30 Central time
November the 22nd 1963 he was shot and
pronounced dead a little more than 30
minutes later had Kennedy lived it's one
of those fascinating questions of
history would the
world have been different I believe yes
we were already involved in Vietnam we
had already sent military advisers there
but Kennedy was reevaluating the
situation I believe he had the political
wisdom the political stature the
political courage to have understood by
1965 not to increase our effort in
Vietnam but to withdraw that one issue
Vietnam for our country apart under
President Johnson it broke the spirit of
that brave and capable man Lyndon
Johnson it led our country to a
divisiveness that we have never overcome
and it also led us to a distrust for our
government a distrust for what we're
told by a president by Congress that
continues to cast a shadow over America
today and in the immediate aftermath of
Vietnam one more country had fallen to
communism so John Kennedy's
assassination changed history and
changed it for the worse
you